gabanusum is the devil you were pretty
strict with the lockdown too you found a
way to allow the motion picture industry
get back to work but you didn't allow
people to grieve together at funerals or
at churches and we didn't know we didn't
know and it was hardly I it was we
collectively mentioned I think all of us
in terms of our Collective wisdom we've
evolved we didn't know what we didn't
know we're experts in hindsight we're
all Geniuses you're prioritized in
industry and one specific one but then
didn't prioritize maybe once it maybe
values you didn't connect with I don't
think it's a binary there was iterations
within that theme what what an evil
mother he has demolished that state he
can't even put it on himself he's the
governor oh it wasn't I it was we are
collective wisdom he locked people in
their houses while he was having dinner
at French Laundry one of the most
expensive restaurants in the United
States with with lobbyists